anna stöhr doppelweltmeisterin im
bouldern und harris leistungssportlerin
beim bundesheer
ich bin halt bei einer chips
kommandantin eingeladen um mir
anzuschauen was da der abc abwehr kaum
von den superstar wird feuergott befehls
gemacht das heißt eben eine lite die
lage erklärt und die aufträge geben das
heißt das auto in ein checkpoint
gefahren ist es ist explodiert der tat
verletzte geben seien jetzt
abtransportiert werden und es ist
effizient wehr gerufen waren mit mir
feststellen welche chemischen
kampfstoffe eingesetzt panzern und wir
schauen uns das an
zwei verschiedene arten von wasser auf
werbung setzen
den muss man deutschland ist der
chemische wasseraufbereitungs platz das
kinderzimmer in einem rohwasser bereich
und im rheinwasser bereich oder neben
das wasser aufbereitet
verdächtiges labor zum beispiel terror
labor also woran wir gerufen werden und
dem herausfinden was da passiert ist ob
der chemische stoffe produziert worden
sein und nehmen auf verschiedene proben
messen mit diverse messgeräte als
stellen fest dass der immer vorhanden
ist an gefährlichen stoffen
ist die krankheit schwer gefallen als
recht interessant finden die do x recht
leicht mit lernen das war vor allem am
anfang sehr anstrengend weil die
körperlichen sondern doch schwieriger
waren für mich wahrscheinlich wie für
manche burschen aber er wird immer
geschaut dass sie aber die ganzen limits
und sowas zur bringe man halbwegs das
gleiche software die burschen und dann
am ende bin ich ja das erste mal und
weltweit
was macht was allgemein als zugs kann
man dann grundsätzlich mal dafür
zuständig dass man den zug führt die
ganze ausbildung plan und wir waren
jetzt im assistenzeinsatz deutschland
dann die klassische führungsaufgabe
drückt wird die aufträge von company
komponenten und muss das dann mit seinem
zug umsetzen und ist dafür
verantwortlich gewesen
wir waren in spiel
wie versprochen sind ein gelände das ist
aufgelassenen steinbruch und da übt
heute unser rettenberger zug
die haben da halt selber gebaut dass man
dafür da zum beispiel bei erdbeben und
ein teil davon ist eben das retten aus
höhen und tiefen und das kommando super
üben
was würdest du einer jungen frau raten
die offizielle laufbahn einschlagen will
also sollte auf jeden fall sportlich
sein ein gewisses selbstbewusstsein
mitbringen oder flexibel sein wenn wir
doch drei jahre in wiener neustadt ist
unter relativ viel unterwegs
es ist jetzt ja verpflichtet das
auslandssemester dass man das machen
muss
das heißt man sollte nicht darauf wert
legen dass man jedes wochenende haben
kommt und viele haben ist weil das
spielzeug nicht und was hast du für die
von ausbildung mit namen
er macht auf jeden fall viel cooler
kurse ich so viel unterwegs krieg echt
viel zum sehen und was nie wirklich am
meisten fasziniert hat so einfach die
kameradschaft in die drei jahren sogar
ernst ein jahrgang wirklich gut kennen
dass ein haufen spaß mit denen und
erlebst einfach wirklich viel